[Applaudissements]
imaginez que caisse comment l'image il
faut être corps de nos consciences
demande et imaginait qu'il ya 50 ans de
ça un petit garçon de 13 ans il veut
changer le monde ont bien évidemment et
il cherche un moyen de s'exprimer et
expliquer au monde ce qu'il voit et sept
enfants notre raison il trouve la
photographie comme médium est à 54 ans
de ça depuis certes il vait élaborer
d'autres choses il va étudier devient
architecte mais la photographie en
autodidacte ça reste au coeur de sa
passion et finalement il veut la seule
chose que faire c'est montrer la réalité
comme vous voyez de 4 et une partie de
la réalité sans intervenir et montrer
aux gens pour cela il se met en route
depuis quarante tendent à la recherche
de ce qui est la vérité ce qui est la
relation nu'man et chaque fois en
utilisant l'appareil photographique
l'image comme le l'histoire pour
parvenir à sa l'une des moyens ceux de
créer des liens entre all les êtres
humaines créé des liens entre l'humanité
et à travers leurs gardes
le regarde les yeux sont le fait naître
de l'âme et il faut essayer juste arrivé
à un moment où on peut créer ce lien
dans leur garde des individus chemin
faisant sur leur route et rencontre
aussi combien la vie est pleine de haut
et bas mais la vie aussi plein de
souffrance il rencontre des réfugiés ait
encore des gens qui fuient une histoire
qui arrive quelque part chez eux ils
sont obligés de partir se réfugier
ailleurs
il va aussi passer beaucoup de temps
dans les zones de guerres et conflits
récemment surtout en kurdistan irakien
où l'état islamique ou des loges
ils ont complètement anéanti toute une
groupe de jean désy et autres et les
villes qu'on me demande détruits et
expliquant que finalement c'est en
voyant ces images si en voyant le
conditionnement qu'on peut commencer à
comprendre et avoir une conscience du
monde parce que tant qu'on n'a pas une
conscience du monde
on n'arrivera pas à le changer quand qu
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe ailleurs
on a toujours l'impression que le monde
c'est seulement celui autour de nous or
pourra montrer ça pour montrer cette
souffrance humaine il faut aller à la
rencontre de ça et ça ça se passe aussi
bien dans les zones dans le guerre mais
aussi comme exemple quand ils
rencontrent toutes ces femmes où ses
filles et idy qui est kidnappé par
l'état islamique d'ardèche et on est
comme esclave sexuelle pendant longtemps
finalement ce qu'ils on revienne quelque
part et raconte leur histoire
certains aussi que finalement ils
prennent des armes pour se défendre ou
défendre ce qu'ils ont vécu ça les
guerres et le conflit s'est pas
seulement destruction des exclus man ou
de bâtiments ne sait aussi affecte le
planète en entier ce qui se passe dans
dans la guerre c'est la souffrance qui
passent dans nos guerres nous voyons
seulement le côté de celui qui restera
espère qu'ils aient le destruction des
bâtiments des êtres humains des animaux
mais la vraie destruction des guerres et
conflits et des astres ces traumatismes
créé dans l'ensemble de l'univers
ces traumatismes et d'ancrer dans
l'ensemble de l'univers ça nous affecte
la même façon qu comme on dit le
battement des ailes de papillon ra
hémisphère nord il faut créer des
tempêtes dans le mystère sud c'est
exactement la même chose donc tout ce
qui se passe dans le monde
ça nous affecte aussi évidemment la
famine c'est une des clés de notre
civilisation actuelle parce que nous
savons que nous pourrons éradiquer
parce que nous savons que c'est possible
avec les moyens que nous avons
d'éradiquer ce genre de souffrance
humaine mais encore pour aller dans
cette direction il faut les voir il faut
le connaître
parce que tant qu'on ne connaît pas
quelque chose on va pas vers ça tant
qu'on ne connaît pas quelque chose on va
pas essayer de le comprendre et de
changer donc mais le monde n'est pas
seulement la souffrance humaine c'est
une mélange c'est comme quotidienne
c'est dans notre vie c'est une presque
mélange entre les joies et souffrances
qu'on se constitue helmand de
continuellement et c'est ça aussi qui
existe dans notre vie de ses seins aussi
que bon tant que photographe
dans ce moment j'essaie de montrer aussi
que il ya aussi le plus importante qui
existent dans le monde qui est la beauté
cette beauté ça peut être aussi sous
différentes formes
ça peut être dans le regard d'un homme
comme massoud un moment qui est en train
de réfléchir à l'avenir de pays ou dans
1 dans une paysage dans camargue et on
peut trouver aussi la beauté parce que
on peut défendre quelque chose qu'on
aime on va pas aller s'intéresser à
quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on
aime pas et c'est de là où ce travail où
l'image que
ça peut devenir une vraie conscience du
monde de mou de nous montrer le côté de
joies et les souffrances de l'humanité
pas de celle ci mais vraiment un vrai
travail de l'image de photographique le
paysage c'est un nom n'ont pas fini dans
le monde entier la beauté de paysages
par tout récemment j'étais tombé dans
une vallée de kurdistan irakien sur cet
arbre magnifique qui est amoureux d'un
rocher et c'est extraordinaire de voir
comment cette liane existe je suis
retourné pendant quatre saisons et
finalement quand je voyais comment la
relation entre cet arbre rocher était
une vraie relation de licques enfin il
fut caresser il y avait une relation
extraordinaire mais malheureusement
l'humanité nous sommes en train de
l'autre côté aussi pour les différents
de raison en train d'anéantir notre
planète
lassé de ce qui est le plus visible
wj tu les poubelles il faut ramasser ça
c'est mais de plus en plus on voit le
monde de remplir de ça mais le plus
important est qu'ils en train d'anéantir
notre planète c'est évidemment le
l'énergie fossile pendant quarante ans
que je me jugeais me suis intéressée à
tous les conflits du monde
je me suis aussi intéressé à la beauté
de l'humanité je me suis aussi intéressé
quelles sont les raisons de ces guerres
80% des raisons de deux guerres
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'énergie fossile et
c'est ça qui est en train de anéantir
notre planète comme on dit au il a une
grotte ils vont ensemble
on ne voit très bien ici a vraiment rohi
d'un blog c'est une très grande chance
de pétroliers on our de la mer caspienne
dans la ville de kazakhstan ou des aussi
en entier les murs entiers qui sont
complètement pris par cette quantité
énorme de pétrole de l'huile qui
rentrait dans les eaux de l'océan dans
dans les zones et phréatique est en
train de complètement mettront près zone
dans notre planète de telle façon que
même ils nous envoient des messages
quand je photographie le mouvement de
des vagues d'une mère avec les huiles
d'un seul coup qu'on voyait ici a le
visage d'une monstre qui montre pour
nous avertir qu'attention ou en face
vous avez mosson il ya des milliers des
milliers des gens d'aujourd'hui qui vit
de ce qui est le poubelle du monde et
isaïe menée sur cet endroit et continue
à vivre et après des fois vous trouvez
la manne d'un ouvrier paysan égyptienne
dans un champ de canne à sucre et qui
vous appelle et quand vous allez le voir
il dit vous savez je suis étudiant de
l'université d'agriculture de guerre
et je viens de toulouse était travailler
ici pour comprendre la terre ça aussi
c'est cette lien qui existe entre la
terre les sciences qui est intéressant
de comprendre dans ses recherches de
l'humanité dans ses recherches de
conditions neumann vous rencontrez aussi
des êtres human des enfants des grandes
qui vit les situations et les
souffrances qui existe sous la terre
mais aussi des fois ils peuvent devenir
avec un mot avec une geste un maître à
penser
je me trouve devant ce garçon il ya une
vingtaine d'années dans une village en
afghanistan où le village complètement
détruit par les bombardements des
aviations us et a plus rien les canaux
d'irrigation lice ont disparu les arbres
tout six ont été arrachés et à toutes
les champs ils sont plaints des mines et
autres et les enfants à l'école comme
nous avons tous fait un moment ils
sortent avec le petit g qui ont fait
pousser dans l'école est il en train
d'aller à la maison dans cette paysage
complètement désastre et quand je les
photographie la fierté qu'il annonce on
regarde ça m'interpelle
comme je parle leur langue je lui
demande que vêtus en faire et sa réponse
cette viennent comme un grande
philosophe qui vous donne le la vie qui
veut ou qui vous montre comment il faut
être dans la vie il me regarde et dit
mais je vais en faire un arbre et cette
phrase de je vais en faire un arbre de
cet enfant de ces devient quelque chose
importante dans la vie de nos tous nous
c'est de créer des arbres de faire des
arbres de tous nos projets de tout ce
que nous faisons de telle façon que
finalement l'ensemble tout ce que je
viens de dix l'utilisation de l'image
pourquoi l'image
il ya cinquante ans ce petit garçon de
13 ans ne croyez que c'est important
parce que notre civilisation
il est rentré dans une nouvelle phase
notre civilisation il est rentré dans
une phase où l'image devient le langage
universel
nous sommes en train d'inventer un
nouvel alphabet comme comme vous voyez
ici
après ce qu'ils étaient il ya 5000 ans
d'autant de l'égyptien maintenant nous
sommes en train d'inventer une nouvelle
forme de de langage parce qu on est en
train de parler au monde entier parce
qu'on d'ici quelques décennies on va
être obligé de parler au monde entier
une langue parlée ou écrit ça ne suffit
pas il faut une nouvelle longue
la nouvelle langue c'est l'image et
c'est cette image qui est en train de
nous montrer la réalité du monde c'est
cette image qui est en train de nous
faire emmener on comprendre ce qui se
passe dans le monde
évidemment en dehors de mon travail
photographe je m'intéresse aussi à la
transmission à la formation de dire que
et les ans légende qui sont en train de
vivre une histoire ils peuvent raconter
leur histoire aussi il faut qu'on voit à
travers leurs gardes
quelle est l'histoire dont je me mets
comme un prof comme formateur comme
educators je vais dans le camp de
réfugiés comme ici c'est le cas d'un
camp de réfugiés d enfants syrienne en
kurde island former les enfants qui
devient le reporter de leur histoire pas
seulement pour qui juste et une appareil
photo et faire des photos mais parce
qu'ils nous racontent leur histoire
parce qu'il devient des solitaires hop
dayz touriste ils prennent en main leur
destin y passe de victimes passif à
acteurs de leur destin
et en plus ils racontent leur histoire
s'appelle dans le camp de réfugiés où ça
m'est arrivé un grand très grand projet
ici à toulouse dans les murailles
formation de 40 jeunes
dans le quartier mirail où pour la
première fois dans l'histoire on a eu
les photographies de quartier mirail
fait par les habitants de mirail et qui
étaient exposées autour de garonne quand
j'avais fait mon exposition ici ou à
dans les salle des illustres de mairie
ou dans le métro toulousain et chaque
fois que je crée ce genre de programmes
projets de formation dans les camps dans
les banlieues du monde ou dans les zones
de guerre c'est toujours dans une idée
de montrer au monde entier de comment ça
se passe un autre moyen de tuer emmener
la photographie au corps de ceux d'une
conscience du monde ce que je fais c'est
lancé des concours photographique pour
les enfants sur le thème écologique
comme celui là que plusieurs milliers
d'enfants dans le monde
ils ont participé à scruter ilove nature
officielle pour lui c'est cette une
moyenne emmener les enfants à participer
et à les voir ce qui est la beauté de
l'humanité ce qui est la pollution c'est
une seul moyen de le faire fort mais on
peut pas les arrivées dans le class et
montrer ce qui se passe juste un système
scientifique
il faut créer des différentes moyen de
jeu et ça c'est une moyenne que les
enfants peuvent s'intéresser aux thèmes
qui nous intéresse iluv natural fils
pollution regardez ce qu'ils font le
travail que ces enfants est vite en 14
ans ils ont produit comme je disais
ensuite le travail de ses enfants des
jeunes des banlieues aux des camps de
réfugiés avec mon travail photographique
je les expose dans le monde entier dans
les endroits comme ici de kate scène
comme il ya eu plusieurs 460 exposition
que je fais depuis une quarantaine
d'années dans le monde entier en
utilisant ce genre de lien ce genre de
relation parce que plus de 50 %
de connaissances human nous avons la
possibilité de transmettre par l'image
et par la photographie il n'y a pas un
seul métier au monde aujourd'hui
qui peut dire moi je peux me passer de
photos je peux ne pas utiliser l'image
tout ce qu'on fait tous les métiers du
monde aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
l'image est ce que j'essaye de faire
depuis 50 ans depuis cet âge de cet
enfant de 13 ans jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est apprendre cette langue et le
transmettre aux autres parce que
transmettent c'est une autre mayan aussi
différemment voilà deux pour transmettre
on peut utiliser les journaux les
magazines comme celle que vous voyez il
ya que des êtres humains enfin mon
travail ou à travers d'autres médias du
monde ou en en créant des livres donc
tous les moyens sont bons les
expositions les conférences pour montrer
parce que ya pas de notre planète n'a
pas et c'est notre responsabilité en
entier pour faire ça et pour arriver à
sauver l'humanité sauver la planète
l'art c'est une des solutions je suis
persuadé que l'art peut devenir pour
sauver le monde
si on a ajouté un peu de ça pour que
devient dans le coeur de l'humanité
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]